[Musique]
donc j'ai fait une saison 2 de scoop à
la une et ensuite les gens de tfm
distillerie tu vas animé le dimanche
après-midi tous le dimanche après midi
et au début j'ai cru moi j'ai dit
pourquoi pas alors je me demandais
comment je vais m'habiller
je pensais déjà à avoir un bureau avec
une soufflerie intégré parce que comme
j'avais le trac j'avais chaud j'avais
déjà tout prévu
et puis un matin je me réveille je me
dis mais thierry qui est absolument
incapable de présenter tout le dimanche
après midi sur tf1
et puis quand j'avais fait scoop à la
une après scoop à la une
j'allais boire des coups aux bains
douches et je me suis dit mais dans le
fond thierry pourquoi tu ne t'es pas
directement une émission aux bains
douches
c'est le principe de plaisir si simple
et plus plaisir de faire une émission
bains douches cogard si l'émission va
être mis aux bains douches
je m'étais pas trompé alors cette
émission qui s'appelait donc bad minuit
est une diffusée sur l'a5 de berlusconi
en fait c'était de rémission alibi toute
la journée il diffuser la petite maison
dans la prairie
et puis le vendredi soir il diffusait
bain de minuit et toute la semaine les
gens parlaient de bain de minuit et
proust est formidable parce qu'ils
pouvaient continuer à diffuser la leur
connerie bain de minuit c'était la
première émission produite par dix son
et lumière chez super inquiet je me
souviens par exemple que la cassette
parce qu'à l'époque ont livré des
cassettes aux chaînes grosse casse est
je suis allée la livre et moi même
tellement j'avais peur qu'elle se
perdent
c'est pour vous dire alors c'est une
époque incroyable l'époque de ben mini
c'était l'époque de la movida parisienne
un roda gil christ sur la croix
les gipsy kings corti mondino qui
d'ailleurs a à imaginer le générique de
l'émission avec la fille qui qui plonge
tout nu dans la piscine des bains
douches
enfin c'était une époque très très
agréable et l'émission raconter cette
époque
l'idée ce n'est pas de montrer les bains
douches tels qu'ils étaient l'idée
c'était d'amener des gens qui n'étaient
jamais allés aux bains douches pour les
mettre fish out of the water les mettre
dans ce bain premier jacques chaban
delmas l'ancien premier ministre avec sa
femme micheline qui est là en bois des
couilles à tout le monde
très à l'aise ça se passe très bien et
ensuite je n'ai eu de cesse d'amener des
hommes politiques ou des femmes
politiques
aux bains douches a commencé par simone
veil dans la simone veil et krasucki
qu'était un bolcho harb de la cgt et qui
était incroyablement surpris de se
retrouver dans cet endroit alors on
tournait tout l'après-midi ont tourné au
sous-sol ont tourné dans la piscine vide
ensuite quand les gens arrivent et on
tournait au restaurant donc en tournée
au milieu des gens etc
c'était vraiment live et puis après il y
avait un after dans le bureau du patron
et je me souviens d'une d'une soirée
mémorable et jack nicholson
on s'est fait des villes de coca jack
nicholson et on a chanté barbry au moins
cent fois ci comme le ba ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba comme ça les vêtements
nous avons se regardant comme des cons
voilà c'était bain de minuit alors
qu'est ce que je vous recommanderais
d'abord pierre combescot grand écrivain
prix médicis qui danse le lac des cygnes
en tutu dans la piscine vide une partie
avec un tutu blanc une partie avec un
tutu noir très sophistiqué il y avait
aussi le chouchou de la semaine
présentée par guy cuevas qui a été le
disquaire du palace alors on a imaginé
un truc par exemple sur la sur la
deuxième guerre mondiale
donc on avait trois épisodes par semaine
premier épisode l'annexion donc on voit
les avions karibe lui les châtelains
quand même il est là il a une loupe
landes il est dans son château il voit
arriver les avions - que ça n'empêchait
pas de dire qu'elle dise qu'il fallait
écouter cette semaine l'a ensuite
l'occupation là on écoute radio londres
ici l'ombre ici londres évidemment le
speaker de l'on disait qu'il fallait
écouter l'époque je crois et et après il
y avait la libération alors la guinée
tel à la libération avec des tractions
est marqué et fait fi voilà on se donne
un mal de chien pour faire 3 minutes par
semaine mais ça mérite d'être regardé il
ya aussi un truc où il joue metropolis
pas un remake de metropolis de fritz
lang qui est très rigolo toujours en
donnant les dix après qu'est ce qu'il
faut regarder pour garder les bois brûlé
un type vraiment l'exemple même du
london chic un ovni entièrement
maquiller une tête d'ovni françoise
sagan l'interlude france 5 ans à qui il
reproche presque d'être impliqué dans
une affaire de cocaïne à lyon et qui
je crois que vous êtes impliqué dans la
même affaire thiery donc j'ai fermé ma
gueule godard et karina ils s'étaient
pas revus depuis 20 ans je les remets
ensemble à un moment elle n'en peut plus
anna karina elle craque complètement
elle se lève pour partir mais à l'époque
elle s'en va avec son fils de micros qui
traîne et merial comme ça c'était pas du
tout télégénique mais il est très
émouvant
il ya aussi une sévillane qu'il faut
regarder c'est des roches en titre et
court on chante avec roda gil et koorkin
c'est via ne vais pas vouloir faire mais
regardez là et puis ce qui se passe
c'est que quand les stars voulait pas
venir aux bains douches
on avait un fond et des carreaux blancs
qu'on apportait là où étaient les stars
on voit l'a fait par exemple avec alice
cooper
on est parti avec neutre est parti avec
notre fonds de carreaux blancs on a mis
ça dans une suite du plaza et on l'a
interviewé devant les carreaux blancs
hier francis bacon aussi francis bacon à
qui j'ai quand même demandé combien de
tableau et baigné par semaine je suis un
peu passé pour 1 contre et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de inhabituel abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux